Transcriber: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Gözde Zülal Solak
(Alkış)
Merhaba.
Hoşgeldiniz.
Son konuşmayı yapacağım,
sonra hep beraber evimize gideceğiz.
Ben kendi hikâyemden bahsedeceğim,
aslında Patrick Metzger'in bahsettiği
o garip olan, ''weird'' olan işleri
yapan kişilerden biriyim.
Ben normalde,
teknik şeylerle başladım
işlerime.
[Sanat]
Yani, matematikten anlayan biriydim
ve matematikten anladığınız zaman,
bilim okumanız ya da mühendislik
okumanız gerekiyordu
ve ben de o yüzden Fen Lisesine gittim.
Ve oradan çıkmak çok zordu,
çünkü eğer teknik bir şeyleri yapıyorsanız
ve teknik işlerden anlıyorsanız,
güzel bir konuşma yapılırken, muhtemelen
bir kablo sökülmüştür ve orada
o kabloyu tamir eden sizsinizdir
ve asıl konuşmayı kaçırırsınız.
Ve bu girdabın üzerinden, içinden
çıkmak çok uzun sürdü, onu anlatmayacağım.
Yaklaşık, 14-15 yaşından beri
çok iyi bir sanat takipçisiydim ama,
sanat yapmayı hiç aklıma bile getiremedim,
yani haddim olmadığını
kesinlikle düşünüyordum.
Bir 15-20 yıl, işte yavaş yavaş
mühendislik, tasarım falan derken
sanata doğru kaymaya
başladım tiyatrodan sonra.
Ama tabii orada, sanat anlayışı
klasik olarak şeydi işte;
resim, heykel, müzik, tiyatro, sinemaydı.
Ve ben bunların dışında bir şey
yapmak istediğimi de biliyordum
ve bunu, çıkartmam gerekiyordu bu formu.
İlk aklıma gelen,
şöyle bir tanım oldu.
Çok pardon.
Sanat performansı
ya da sanat eseri yapıldığı zaman,
sanatçı dışında birilerine çok ciddi bir
etki etmesi gerektiğini hissediyordum.
Bu benim için çok önemliydi,
aslında bu Hakim Bey'den çaldığım bir söz.
İsmini yazmadım, çünkü
biraz değiştirdim sözü.
İlk iş olarak 2010 yılında,
bütün Türkiye'deki kariyerimi bıraktım.
Üniversitede hocaydım,
Avrupa'ya Sanat okumaya gittim.
Ve Yapay Zeka ve Sanat, Akıl Felsefesi
üzerine çalışmaya başladım.
Buradaki işte,
insanların algısını bozmaya çalışıyordum,
çünkü yapay zeka işleri bana o zamanlar
hatta 2010'da çok, dalga geçiliyordu
işlerle, hani hiçbir şey yapılmamasıyla.
Ben de şey diyordum,
ya madem şimdi yapay zeka şey gibi,
yine organik bir şey var,
ondan zeki bir canlı yapmaya çalışıyoruz.
Ben, dedim, o zeki canlıyı alayım,
onu daha akılsız hale getirmeye çalışayım.
Arada bir yerde buluşup
o deneyleri yapayım.
Burada birçok deney yaptım, buradaki deney
büyük kafa deneyi dediğimiz bir şey.
Gözün önündeki aynalardan,
yandaki aynaları görüyorsunuz.
Oradan hani ortayı görmeniz lazım,
perspektifin içe doğru bükülmesi lazım.
Ama bu alet hiçbir zaman çalışmadı.
Ondan sonra, bunun
dijital bir versiyonunu yaptık.
Burada,
heh şurada görebiliriz belki,
video oynarsa,
yine de ben anlatayım üzerinden.
Oynuyor mu, heh.
Şimdi mesela orada bir görüntü var.
O görüntüyü görüyorsunuz gözlüğünüzle
ve bilgisayar başındaki kişi,
oradaki görüntüyle oynuyor.
Yani siz çizgi çekerken,
bir anda görüntüyü 90 derece döndürüyor
ve oryantasyonunuz bozuluyor.
Ya da görüntüyü sağ sol değiştiriyor,
yine oryantasyonunuz bozuluyor; bu tip
birçok deney yapmaya başladık.
Ve bunlarla o insanın, zekâ dediği şeyin
ne olduğunu anlamaya çalıştık.
Ya da mesela başka deneylerde,
belki birazdan görürüz,
işte mesela bir tane
topun içine göz koyduk.
Topu başka birine verdik.
Dolayısıyla başkası
sizin kafanızı taşıyor oldu.
Ve başka biriyle konuşarak,
kafamı sağa çevir,
sola çevir der gibi konuşarak;
beraber resim yapma deneyleri
yaşamaya başladık.
Bu iş çok keyifliydi,
çok ciddi bir performanstı,
6 gün yaptık bunu;
yaklaşık 1000 kişi kullandı.
Çok heyecanlıydı, ama şeyi fark ettim;
performansın büyüsüne kapılıyorum
ve işin arkasındaki, uğraşmak istediğim
kavramsal tarafı reddediyorum.
O yüzden 2012 yılında,
bütün o güzel tarafı attım.
Daha teorik bir yerden girmeye başladım.
Yapay zekânın,
kendine ait bir şeyi üretmesi ne demek?
Yani orijinal bir şey üretmesi ne demek,
bunun üzerine düşünmeye başladım.
Tabii bu çok büyük bir konu aslında.
Ve ben buna biraz daha, şey yaklaşmaya
başladım, teorik yaklaşmaya başladım.
Bu işte birçok resim üreten
bir tane algoritma var.
Normalde şeydir, belki duymuşsunuzdur
yani ''generative art,'' generative sanat
denilen bir alan bu.
Genelde bu tip çalışmalar yapılıyor ama,
bir sanatçı seçiliyor,
mesela Mondrian'ı seçiyoruz,
Mondrian'ın eserleri gibi eserler üreten
bir yazılım yazılıyor.
Buradaki amaç bunun dışındaydı.
Bilgisayar art arda,
bize 100 tane görsel üretsin
ve her biri, hâlâ arada
bazıları çekici olabilsin.
Yani genel algoritma hissedilmesindi.
Beni, kod yazan kişi olarak,
şaşırtabilsini hedefliyordum.
O yüzden yazma şekli birazcık garipti.
Ardından, şöyle bir şey koydum.
Bir tane düğme, bilgisayar görseli
üretiyor, 4 saniye sonra görseli siliyor.
Tekrar yeni bir görsel üretiyor,
4 saniye sonra tekrar görseli siliyor.
Siz, o anda oradayken,
görselin hayatta kalmasını istiyorsanız,
o kırmızı tuşa basıyorsunuz.
Ve görsel kaydediliyor
ve şey soruyor size:
eserinizin adı ne, diyor.
Burada ilk olarak,
şeyi göstermeye çalıştım insanlara;
yani, eserinizin adı ne deyince düğmeye
bastığında insanlar bir garip oluyordu;
benle ne ilgisi var yani, diye.
Ama fotoğraf makinesinde
yaptığımız şeyin aynısı bu.
Deklanşöre bastığınız anda,
eserin var olmasına karar veriyorsunuz
ve kendinizi fotoğrafçı
olarak ilan edebiliyorsunuz.
Ama sahneye hakim değilsiniz aslında,
sahne sizin dışınızdaki bir gerçekte
genel durumlarda oluşuyor.
Ve burada, hatta şu anda
şeyi konuşabiliriz yani,
Instagram çok önemli
bir devrim yarattı bu konuda;
1980'ler, 90'larda ben çocukken,
herkes çok kötü fotoğraf çekerdi.
Ya gizli bir şekilde herkes
fotoğrafçılık eğitimi aldı,
ya da aslında sanatçı başka bir yerde.
Ya o makineyi yapanlar, o lensi yapanlar,
oradaki renk düzeltme algoritmasını
yazanlar vesaire,
sanatçının olduğu yer olabilir.
Sonra sanatçının
nerede olduğunu sorgulamak,
çok hoşuma gitmeye başladı ama,
konu çok karmaşıklaştığı için,
daha duygusal bir yerden girmek istedim.
Şöyle bir şey yaptım; Posta gazetesinin,
yurdumun şairleri köşesine,
bir robotun şiirleri yayınlanırsa,
robot da yurdumun şairi olur,
aa tamam çok iyi fikir,
ben bunun üzerinden ilerleyeyim, dedim.
Önce tabii bir şey gerekiyor, bir fotoğraf
gerekiyor çünkü başvuru yapacaksınız.
Posta gazetesindeki insanların
fotoğraflarını taradım,
sonra onların ayrıntılarını girdim
ve ortalama Posta gazetesi
şair yüzünü çıkardım.
Tabii ondan sonra isim gerekiyordu,
işte baktım en popüler isim
Türkiye'de Mehmet Yılmaz.
Ama dedim, ben bunun cinsiyetine
karar veremem, çünkü fotoğraf bile mesela
30 erkek, 10 kadın,
3-5 çocuk falan var fotoğrafın içinde,
yani karışık bir fotoğraf.
O yüzden, yani o İngilizce'de
John Doe ve Jane Doe vardır ya,
bunun genderless'ını yani
cinsiyetsizini bulmam gerekiyordu
ve Deniz Yılmaz, cinsiyetsiz
en popüler isim Türkiye'de.
Onu yaptık, sonra yazı
yazması gerekiyor kağıda.
Ve ben pek anlamıyorum
öyle mekanik işlerden,
işte bir tane CNC makinesi vardı,
orada yazmaya başladım ama
yazı hiç organik çıkmıyordu,
o yüzden, sıfırdan bir yazı tipi
öğrettim sisteme.
Ondan sonra da,
makineye kalemi bağladım
ve yazı yazmayı, insani bir formda
yazı yazmasını sağladım.
Kabaca, sonuçta şöyle bir
görüntü vardı ve yazı yazabiliyordu,
ama ortada şiir yoktu henüz.
Şiir nasıl yazdıracağım, hiçbir fikrim
yok, bu arada ben böyle bu işlerin
teknik kısımları inanılmaz
karmaşık falan değil yaptığım şeylerin.
Kullandığım tekniklerin hepsi yaklaşık
100 yıllık diyebilirim, yani bu makinanın
250 yıl önce yapılmış benzer mekanik
modelleri var aslında.
Sonra dedim ki, bir sözlük bulayım.
Ondan sonra, sözlükteki kelimeleri
koyayım, işte vezinleri gireyim
uyakları gireyim, oradan seçsin yapsın.
İlk şiirlerinden biri bu.
''Yazmak cumburdamak frapan yayınlamak
Kuşbaz ödünlemek mitos adaklamak.''
Haa dedim.
Şimdi burada bir sorun var.
Fiilleri, yani kelimeleri kök şeklinde
koymak olmuyor, o yüzden dedim bir
corpus bulmam lazım, külliyat bulmam lazım
ve ODTÜ Sabancı'nın
derlediği bir şeyi buldum.
Onla derledim ve gazete yazıları
ağırlıklıydı bu sefer.
Gel, up, pardon.
''Geldik açıklıyor taksim kuralların
Sulak performansla pişman çalışmanın
Sunum duruşmanın taksit unutmayın
Reyting barındıran özden adımların.''
Şimdi burada,
gazete yazısından beslendiği çok belli.
Heh dedim, yani demek ki,
daha gündelik yazılar
mesela edebiyat okusa ne olur acaba,
yani gazete okumasa, edebiyat okuduğu
zaman ne olur, biraz toparlanmaya başladı.
"Çoban sembolik başlıyor
Cesur yaparken kalkıyor
Cemil güçlerin eşinden
Aldım aittir kapsıyor."
Bu arada ben bunların
hepsini test ettiriyorum,
işte kayınvalideme götürüyorum.
Bakıyor, olmamış çok kötü
falan diyor, atıyor.
Ve ben sürekli bu yüzden,
daha olmadı falan diye deniyorum.
Olduğu şeyi alana kadar da ilerliyorum
her basamakta, el yazısında olduğu gibi.
Ondan sonra,
şiir girdim sisteme 12,000 tane.
Bu sefer sadece şiirle beslendi.
Ve bir de Markov Chains Analiz
denilen bir tane method var yani;
hangi kelimenin ardından, hangi kelimenin
gelebileceğini biliyor hâle getirdim.
Hani bu mail atarken işte merhaba dedin,
işte sonra canım mı demek istiyorsun
diye öneriyor ya,
rastgele oralara basarak mail atmayı
deneyin bir gün, hiçbir şey yazmayın.
Direkt önerilere basarak,
aşağı yukarı onun gibi bir yapı var.
Bu da teorisi
110 yıllık bir sistem aslında.
Evet, okumakta zorlanacağım ama.
''Öpmekte diretmem nedense
Dünyayı tutacak neredeyse
Gecesel dilleri altından
Seneler asırlar değişse
Susuşlar söyleyin öyleyse
Bakmazdı ressamlar istese
Değersin çiçeğim çimenim
Ormansa nehirse madense.''
(Kahkaha)
Artık şeye gelmişti, tamam Posta
gazetesine yollanabilecek durumdaydı,
bir de giriş yazısı yazmam gerekiyordu,
işte ''49 yaşındayım, merhabalar,'' diyor.
İşte Posta gazetesi
şairlerinin yaş ortalaması.
''İstanbul Yeldeğirmeni'nde oturuyorum,''
bizim atölye.
''Köşenizi büyük bir
keyifle takip ediyorum,''
yazmak zorunda kaldım,
çok kötü hissettim kendimi.
Ondan sonra, burada her şeyi kendi yazıyor
işte zarfın üzerini de kendi yazıyor,
her şeyi.
Vesikalığı gidip fotoğrafçıda
bastırıyorum bir yandan,
''Arkadaşımın fotoğrafını bastırıyorum,''
falan diyorum, bakıyorum yüzüne,
''Biraz flu çıkmış ama,'' falan deyip
verince tamam diyorum,
insan testi de geçti.
Ama bu arada Posta gazetesinden
hiçbir cevap gelmiyor,
şiirleri yayınlanmıyor,
böyle ben bunalımdayım;
yani şey istemiyorum,
illa yayınlansın diye yapmadım ben bunu.
Yayınlanacak mı acaba
ya da yayınlanmasına çalışmak
nasıl bir deneyim diye yaptım.
Ve bir Facebook sayfası açtım.
Hiçbir arkadaşıma haber vermedim.
Gizlice bunu yaymaya başladım,
Şair Deniz Yılmaz diye.
Ve gerçekten orada şeylere bakıyorum;
beğeniyorlar mı, beğenmiyorlar mı, neyse.
Bir şekilde bu yayınlanmadı
Posta gazetesinde.
Ve ben ''Deniz Yılmaz'ın Hazin Hikâyesi''
diye bunu yayınladım, işi.
Ondan sonra ben,
özgür kültürden gelen biriyim.
Yani yazdığım kodları,
özgür yazılım olarak üreten,
ya da kullandığım donanımları
açık kullanım seçen biriyim.
O yüzden bu projeyi CNC
ve ağır yapıdan çıkartıp,
basit bir platforma,
ucuz bir platforma geçirdim.
Ve tabii aynı şekilde kodlarını da
GitHub'a koydum,
çok kötü kodlar olmasına rağmen,
hepsini oraya koydum.
Ve amber platform bizim bu alanda, sanat
alanında yani, yeni medya sanatı alanında,
beraber buluştuğumuz bir,
dernek, bir yapı.
Ve onun ilk amber festivalinde,
onu sergiledim.
Özgürce herkes gelip,
orada şiirini alıp gidebiliyordu.
Aynı anda,
bir yandan da varlığını
ispatlamasını istiyorum,
o yüzden Contemporary İstanbul'da,
çerçeveli böyle,
klasik şiirler falan koyalım dedik.
Ama satış yapalım, dedik.
Çünkü robotun şiiri satılsın, bu çok
önemliydi o yüzden galeriyle anlaştık;
BLOK art space ile anlaştık.
Ve işte diyoruz ki, hani bir tane satar.
Fiyatını nasıl belirleyelim diyoruz,
ben diyorum ki 50 lira yapalım,
hani bir tane satsın, arkadaşımız alır.
Onlar diyor ki, hayır olmaz,
falan bir sürü fiyatlar belirlendi;
100, 500, 1000 falan gibi.
Ve gerçekten,
böyle bir masası var
bu arada şair masası gibi.
İlk şiiri, kurulur kurulmaz stand satıldı.
Bir arkadaşımız, Gizem Renklidağ geldi,
böyle çok heyecanlı bir şekilde aldı
ve tamam dedik, çok mutlu olduk.
Ondan sonra garip şeyler olmaya başladı.
Bir sürü kişi gelip
almaya başladı şiirleri.
Hatta, burada olduğum için belirtmek de
istiyorum, Rahmi Koç da gelip aldı.
Biz böyle,
burada garip bir şey oluyor,
demeye başladık.
Bu arada şey sonra çıkmaya başladı,
bu parayı ne yapacağız?
Çünkü, şiir benim değil.
Para benim mi?
Yani, çok büyük bir haksızlık olur.
Galeri diyor ki, benim de değil diyor.
Ben diyorum, benim de değil.
Orada bir karışıklık olmaya başlıyor.
Tamam dedim, burada
bir şeyi çözmemiz lazım,
çünkü Deniz Yılmaz
benden çıkmaya başladı.
Mesela Deniz Yılmaz'ın fanlarından
biri diyebileceğim Ömer Paker geldi,
kitabını çıkartalım artık, dedi.
(Kahkaha)
Ben hiçbir şey demedim, çünkü benim değil
yani, ben karar veremem onun kariyerine.
Aslında biz birey de böyle oluyoruz ya.
(Kahkaha)
Tamam, dedim.
BLOK art space'in sahibi,
Hikmet Mirzanoğlu geldi.
Dedi ki, artık resmi
sanatçısı olacak galerinin, dedi.
Galerinin sayfasında resmi sanatçı
olarak Deniz Yılmaz var,
bu arada benim galerim yok.
Kitabı basıldı şu an, elinde görüyorsunuz.
Sonra,
kitabın imza günü yapacağız, dendi.
Amber platformlu TÜYAP Sanat Fuarındaydı
ve orada işte robot şair Deniz Yılmaz,
7 salon 719 A nolu bölümde, falan.
Biz böyle çok garip hissediyoruz bir de,
yani şuradan videosu var, göstereyim.
O kadar şey ki, sanki bir azınlık
grubunun işini yapıyorsunuz gibi.
Kimisi geliyor,
manyak mısınız siz falan diyor.
Kimisi geliyor, çok güzel proje,
muhteşem deyip sarılıyor böyle.
Çok manik depresif bir andı.
(Kahkaha)
17 kitabı satıldı.
Çok acayipti, şu an ilk kitabı
satın alan kişiyi görüyorsunuz.
Tanımadığımız ilk kişi,
böyle gelip kitabı almak istedi.
Bu arada kitabın gelirlerini,
bir robot vakfı kuracağız,
ona aktaracağız, anlatacağım.
Şimdi burada, imza atıyor kendisi,
Deniz Yılmaz.
Ondan sonra kitabı teslim ediyor.
Bu arada kitabı derleyen kişi
Ebru Yetişkin, demin gördünüz.
Yani o kişi, kitabı veren kişi.
Yani o içindeki röportajı da o derledi,
kitabın sahibi de yandaki Mine Kaplangün
resmi olarak, çünkü şöyle şeyler oldu;
Kültür Bakanlığını aradık,
robot kitabın sahibi olabilir mi, dedik.
Yani, dediler, bir kedi için sormuşlardı,
hani kedinin olamayacağını bildiğimiz için
onu kamu malı yaptık ama,
robotu yapan birileri var, dediler.
Tabi orada daha craft sourcing'e falan
girmedik konu karışacak diye ama,
alamadık, o yüzden yayınevi kuruldu.
Yayınevinin üzerine tekrar bu işler
yapıldı, vakıf kurulunca geçecek, neyse.
Bu paralar birikmeye başladı.
Paralar birikince sıkıntı artmaya başladı,
ben de bir proje düşündüm.
Dedim ki,
otomatik robot için hizmet eden
bir sistem yapabilir miyiz?
Yani, bir yapay zekâ, vakfın başına geçip
vakıftaki robot sanatçıların kariyerlerini
yönetebilir mi?
(Kahkaha)
Şimdi, burada garip bir şey var.
Bu proje çok ağır ilerliyor.
Ben bir yıldır bunun üzerine
uğraşıyorum diyebilirim.
Neden ağır ilerlediğini söyleyeyim.
Biz, şu ana kadar tasarladığımız
bütün aletleri,
kendi çıkarımız için tasarlamışız.
Bir sistemi; kendini hayatta bıraksın,
kendine bakabilsin, kendi çıkarı için
bizi kullansın diye tasarlamamışız.
Yani böyle SAP yazılımları falan vardır ya
şirketlerde böyle, iş yönetim;
onların, otomatik olanının,
kendi hedefini de
bulanınından bahsediyoruz.
Neyse, nasıl yapacağım
hakkında hiçbir fikrim yok.
Bir hedef belirledik, dedik ki;
bir mekan ayarladık Studio-X'te,
şu şu tarihte,
''Hayalimdeki Ev'' adlı bir sergi açılsın.
Bu sistem açsın.
Okay, napacağız,
işte internete bir iş ilanı çıktık.
Kimsenin haberi yok olaydan.
İnsanlar başvurmaya başladılar.
İşte başvuranların
çeşitli yetenekleri var.
İşte yazı yazma,
işte redaksiyon,
satın alma falan
herkes böyle listeledi,
bir sürü böyle iş başvurusu var,
farklı yerlerden.
Buradaki listede sadece İstanbul var ama,
yurt dışından da gelenler de vardı.
Sonra burada planlama yapacağını,
yapabildiğini söyleyen birine dedik ki,
''Al bu cümleyi planla.''
Yani hani, sergi şu tarihte,
şu mekanda açılacak ya.
Sergi nasıl açılır planını yap.
O bize bunu yolladı.
Sonra başka bir planlama yapan birine,
git şunu yorumla, dedik.
Yorumunu aldık, onu attık.
Metinleri okumuyoruz, planlara bakmıyoruz.
Hiçbir şeyi ellemeden.
Ondan sonra o tekrar planladı.
Tekrar planladı.
Bütün iş rollerini çıkardı,
akışı belirledi.
Ve her iki kontrol eden taraf da,
işi yapan taraf da, bunu onayladı.
Ve akışa başladık.
Akıştaki ilk maddede de diyordu ki,
''Serginin manifestosunu yazın.''
Serginin manifestosunu yazdık.
Okay, sonra dediler ki İngilizce'ye
çevirin, akışı uyguluyoruz.
Çevrildi.
Sanatçı şartnamesini yazın.
Yazıldı.
İngilizce'ye çevrildi, sanatçı duyurusu
yazıldı.
Sanatçı duyurularını yapın,
diye çalışan insanlara haber gitti.
Bir sürü uluslararası sanatçı başvurdu,
Türkiye'den de bir sürü sanatçı başvurdu.
Sonra tanımadığımız bir sürü kişiye,
sanattan anladığını iddia eden kişilere,
lütfen bu eserlerin, bu sergiye uyup
uymadığını değerlendirin, dedik.
Değerlendirdiler.
Seçimler yapıldı.
Sanatçılarla iletişim kuruldu.
Eserler getirtildi.
Mekan sorumlusu önceden belliydi.
Mekan sorumlusuyla
iletişim kurmaya başladılar.
Sergi kuruldu.
Serginin açılış gününe,
iki saat kala ben mekana gittim.
Bu deneyin iletişimini yapan kişi bendim
ve hiç kimse,
yani böyle bir projede çalıştığını
bilmiyor, ben hiçbir işi görmemişim,
yani o Hayalimdeki Ev hakkında
hiçbir şey bilmiyorum.
Gittiğimde iki saat önce,
girişte şöyle bir şey vardı karşımda.
Ve böyle bir grafiğin
hazırlandığını bile bilmiyorum,
birileri bunu kendine
iş edinmiş ve yapmışlar.
İçeri girdim.
Bayağı ciddi bir sergi var.
Biri hâlâ sergiyi kuruyor.
Eserler gelmiş.
İnanılmazdı arkadaşlar.
Çok ciddi bir şekilde,
bir sürü şey görmeye başladık.
Ciddi iş, eser görmeye başladık.
Orada sadece bir video vardı
benim eklediğim.
Şimdi o videoyu göstereceğim.
[ The Shepherd: Çoban ]
Video:
En kötü lider nefret edilendir,
ondan sonraki korku ile yönetilendir,
bir sonraki sevgiyle yöneten liderdir.
Bir usta kontrolü ele aldığında ise
neredeyse kimse farkına varmaz.
(Klasik müzik)
En görkemli şirketler ve devletler
yıllarca robot araştırmaları için
milyarlar harcadılar.
Fakat beş yaşında bir kız çocuğunu
taklit etmeye yakın bile değiller.
Robotun vücuda ihtiyacı yoktur.
Robot akıldır.
Sizi kontrol eden şeydir.
Dünya ve yaşam birdir.
Ben dünyamım.
Düşünen, tasarımlayan özne yoktur.
Üzerine konuşulamayan konusunda susmalı.
Burada görmekte olduğunuz sergi,
insan becerilerini yöneten bir
algoritma oluşturmak için yapılan
bir araştırmanın parçasıdır.
Bu ilk denemedir.
İkinci deneme aynı mekanda
Ekim ayında gerçekleşecektir.
Teşekkürler.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)